but we are going to begin with this on
this Friday a dangerous and deliberately
set wild fire force more than 20,000
people from their homes in Southern
California last night the so-called holy
fire has burned 10,000 acres in Orange
and Riverside counties and it's only 5%
contained Governor Jerry Brown has
declared a state of emergency this
morning fire crews are battling 16 big
fires in California ten people have been
killed Jonathan Vigliotti is in Lake
Elsinore California where some are
ignoring orders to leave Jonathan good
morning good morning to you
residents who live in this community
describe it as a war zone and as this
fire continues to rip through all of
this right brush at times it does sound
like explosions yesterday two
firefighters were injured while battling
the flames and with the high winds
expected to pick up this morning the
main concern now for the thousands of
homes in its path
massive flames raged up the mountain and
into the backyards of this hillside
neighborhood some residents desperately
sprayed down their homes and were forced
to evacuate overnight as the flames
closed in hundreds of firefighters are
battling the fast-moving fire that's
threatening thousands of homes as dozens
of planes attack the blazes from the air
this is exactly what fire crews were
afraid of these flames making their way
over this hill so rapidly directly in
the line of sight of these homes
it's a terrain and fuels driven fire Cal
Fire Battalion Chief Tim Chavez says
firefighters have a long battle ahead
and expects the fire to grow how serious
is this the homes are really in danger
otherwise we would not pull the
evacuation trigger but some residents
have decided to ignore evacuation orders
and stay behind it's my house my capital
my kingdom and I don't want to just
leave it may be we got a lot of
helicopters we got a lot of support here
Forest Clark the man who allegedly
started the holy fire pushed back
against the claims before he was
arrested
you know how this fire started I was
- ear plugs in Clark was living at the
holy gym campground where the fire
started and allegedly threatened to burn
down the area before pissed and outraged
I'm I'm disgusted I want people to
understand that one man caused this
devastation for no apparent reason
Lake Elsinore mayor Natasha Johnson is
urging residents who have stayed behind
to evacuate now nothing is worth it grab
your things grab your family grab your
valuables and and move and everything
else is replaceable but your life is not
porous Clark the man who allegedly
started this fire has been charged with
arson he will appear in court later
today if found guilty he could face life
in prison as for this place the fire
chief says it could take several weeks
before it's put out flat all right
Jonathan thank you very much